I'm pregnant
Brian
whenever you're ready just
Ryan Cabrera and WWE star Alexa Bliss
expecting their first child she just
happened to be the most incredible
person I've ever met he's like you just
tell me what you want tell me what you
like and we'll just I'll make it happen
and he has the happy couple revealed the
news in Ryan's newest music video for
his song RX and through inspiration from
the 90s sitcom Friends
hi
um I think there's something we really
need to talk about
I think we do
it's about prom why don't we go inside
I'm pregnant
Brian
[Laughter]
whenever you're ready just
he loves it and he thinks it's so fun
the two also shared the news on the gram
posing together for a sweet pregnancy
photo shoot Alexa writes in the
heartfelt caption the best moments in
life are the completely unexpected baby
Carrera arriving December 2023
[Music]
as for Ryan check out his excitement in
the silly snaps writing is there a word
that's even more exciting than excited
yeah that's how I feel the couple tie
the knot in April 2022 after two years
of dating we became amazing friends and
that turned into the most incredible
relationship yep and these shared clips
from the big day in Ryan's music video
worth it now every time we get to see it
yeah we're like oh my God that was you
know hands down Best Day Of Our Lives
[Music]
that whole day was everybody was like
I've never felt so much love and it
wasn't even I mean me and Lexi as well
but just just everybody yeah together
I'm that guy like I love romantic
comedies I cry and all that crap like
you know I'll admit it I don't care I am
the hopeless romantic